my name is Alana Bennish and I am 38
years old I born blind
I had many surgeries and they have
succeeded to improve my sight in one eye
independency means access many of the
technologies that available today are
not accessible and that's why I came to
move lickable anyways we have I'm the
program manager of Champa selfie which
is a Google space that is dedicated to
entrepreneurs and startups meaning
helping the local ecosystem to create
amazing startups I started thinking how
is it possible that this huge market is
not being addressed because if they knew
that with some easy steps they can
actually make their app accessible to
the sheet market I was sure that they
bound to do something about this so this
is how the idea of this problem of
applicable started my name is Arielle
Kayden I'm mobile product manager fiber
fiber is a marketplace for creative
professionals we're helping people
productize and make money from the
talent 5 is trying to change how people
work
and allowing people with disabilities to
work with fiber is something being so we
started with visually impaired and blind
people each table had a start-up mentors
from the design world the product world
and developers set together with person
with visual impairment and a person who
is blind to see how he's actually using
his an app my name is Jonathan and her
developer and evangelist in get get is a
leading platform for on-demand services
like get taxi or and get pizza or even
get the doctor and remember at the
beginning it was a woman saying are you
from get I'm not talking with you like
you are make my life awful when you make
this difference for them personally feel
proud you're like you really help
someone one of the really small changes
that we did that has huge impact was
that we have when you open the app we
have marketing pop up right straight on
the screen and it doesn't have any label
so for the for the blind people was like
home we're sort of showing a regular map
with the address and and ordered taxi
button and it wasn't what's the world
that they're actually the marketing pop
up and they can't click on anything or
using the topic and by just verifying
that if you're the top book is turned
off not to showing this pop-up it's like
huge difference because now these people
were able to order text instead of
constantly clicking on the marketing
poppin understanding why can't order a
taxi actually that the impact was that
she went out of the building they say oh
now able to order a taxi
we actually did some really small change
we have a page categories within fiber
it was built like poor category next to
a category and a very long page and when
we did one of the session they just tell
me just building one in one in row
not one next to each other so we change
it we put it in they have on page and
just change dramatically how people
navigate their thinking about a simple
experience it just made me a better
product manager but it's a really small
effort just to change little bit bytes
of code to add additional stuff and you
can make really huge difference for them
for their daily they tagging your
components on a specific page giving a
an image the right
it's really something that when you
change how you think it's very simple
enable the accessible view on your phone
try to use the phone as someone who just
for example can see this will affect
everything you do
dramatically ninety-six unlabeled button
13 unlabeled but in 74 unlabeled button
but an 18 unlabeled button 35 unlabeled
button Esther we did a disaster so after
about half a year that the adult of the
visual impairment and blindness we went
to the second stage of the program and
addressed people with motor disabilities
so again we open testing labs we bought
the Mentos we bought people with
disabilities we bought startups and we
realized that this is definitely
something that is so needed thank you
for joining and start running try to
send message during the running you will
have a lot of respect
you need to duration we type events and
we type and this is my life when I'm
using a new heart I'm 39 years old and
working and get as they senior engineer
I have several Foley and the effect of
that you can see my speeches I have a
difficult speech and by the light and is
functional and also both the legs are
not function and I have only one hand
and even in I think I have three fingers
I have a spastic it's very difficult to
to touch to reach all the corners with
one finger my wildest dream that I will
have the ability to put every each
button that I want another thing the
diviners and logics wouldn't of that but
[Music]
meet with them to tell them our needs it
was very very important meetings my
message to all developers will be hey
guys you are there you actually the one
that can have the power to change a lot
of people the entirely like I think
about this amazing applicable session
every stream page or button the time
adding to that we got more Tiffany you
too much from our accessible apps are
changing our lives every day and will
continue to change everybody's life
every day
[Music]